-You -- you worked here.
Is there anything you learned
from working here
that now that you're in charge,
you're bringing to that project?
-Well, I learned a lot from you.
Like, every morning I walk into
the writers' room,
and I reference a foreign film
that no one has possibly seen.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Did you see
'The Dark Trombone'"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Everyone in Slovenia is
talking about it."
-No, I think that's a thing
people like.
-Mm. Yeah, no one ever --
no one ever watches them.
-I always assumed that
after I left the room
you all talked about
how exciting it was
that I told you about a film
you didn't want to see.
-Yeah, that's what we said.
[ Laughter ]
That's definitely what we said.
-Do you think
you're a good boss so far?
-I mean, I'm really lucky
because I have --
I don't have any Michelles
on my staff.
[ Laughter ]
So all my writers
are really nice.
-Yeah.
You would even write things
on purpose
just because you wanted to hear
me say them.
You didn't think
they would work.
-Yes.
-You just thought
they would delight you
because I would fail,
and you enjoyed my failure.
-It's fun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Is there anything -- is there
anything that you're not good at
that they figured out
that they want to make you do?
-Yeah, no, they figured out
almost immediately
that I can't do accents.
-Yeah.
-And so they write into a lot of
the jokes, me doing an accent,
and I can't do --
like, I can't do any accent.
I can barely do my voice.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, your voice seems like
it takes a lot of energy.
-It is!
[ Laughter ]
It's so hard!
-The fact that -- I mean,
the fact that you --
I mean, with the calories you
burned in that 50-mile race,
how did you have anything left
to speak for, like, days?
-Oh, it was easy,
I'm telling you.
You wouldn't have been able
to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, let's try --
can we try some accents?
Just don't think of it.
Clear your head.
Scottish.
-[ Foreign accent ]
The little doggie...
[ Laughter ]
...went golfing.
-What? Little doggie what?
-The little doggie went golfing.
[ Laughter ]
-Australian.
-[ Australian accent ]
Down under we have sharks.
[ Laughter ]
-Way better.
-[ Normal voice ]
That wasn't too bad.
-No, that was better.
It's certainly better than
"little doggie went golfing."
-I don't know why I feel like
I have to say something
they would say.
-Yeah, right.
Well, every time you meet
anyone,
they give you two details
about their country.
Germany.
-[ German accent ]
Das, no, ya, okay!
[ Laughter ]
-That was your best one.
That was by far your best one.
[ Laughter ]
You mentioned -- I heard you say
that the nice thing
about you having your own show
is you can now tell jokes
that you wouldn't --
either your bosses on your old
shows, "The Daily Show" or here,
wouldn't be able to say
or wouldn't let you say.
What are some of the subjects
you're tackling that you can --
you have the freedom to do now?
-[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, I got a lot of fun stuff
that you wouldn't let me do.
-What kind of stuff?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait until they laugh at
this one.
You know what's great about
a joke -- when you set it up.
[ Laughter ]
I'll tell jokes like,
well, like, when Hillary --
it's like, I really wanted to
have the first female president.
It'd be great to have Hillary
be the president,
because then you could show
that women can do anything
as long as their husband
did it first.
[ Laughter ]
And I would have loved to have
Bill Clinton
as the First Gentleman
because the spouse of
the President
is the one who sometimes give
tours of the White House,
and I would have loved to see
Bill be like,
"These are our drapes.
They're covered in my semen."
[ Laughter ]
"Everything in this office is
covered in my semen."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't turn on a black light."
-I think that's
an excellent advertisement
for "The Break
with Michelle Wolf" on Netflix.
I'm so happy for you.
I can't wait to see
your new show,
and it's just always so
wonderful to have you here.
-Hey, thanks.
You said "here" wrong.
[ Laughter ]
It's so wonderful
to have you "herr."
Did you turn into 50 Cent
at the end of that?
[ Laughter ]
-It's so -- it's so great to
have you "her."
-I'm sorry, that's Nelly!
-What?
-Nelly. Sorry.
-Let's look --
-Don't end the segment, Seth!
-Yeah, that's right.
When I end the segment, you have
to go back to work.
Give it up for Michelle Wolf,
everybody.